y si hay un país llamado a unirse a
brasil a argentina como la próxima
selección sudamericana clasificada a
qatar es el ecuador la tricolor necesita
solamente un punto para volver a una
copa del mundo después de su ausencia en
la cita de rusia 2018 los ecuatorianos
ya están en la asunción para su duelo
frente a paraguay tienen mucho de cara
para estar en qatar de hecho una
victoria de uruguay ante perú en esta
fecha del jueves también les daría el
pase directo al ecuador que piensa el
seleccionador gustavo alfaro
para mí y jugar una copa del mundo de
poder hacerlo va a ser el hecho más
significativo de 30 años de carrera más
allá de como bien marcadas me tocaron
cosas muy lindas en mi carrera y me
tocado en unos momentos muy duros
también como le ha tocado a todo el
mundo pero obviamente que jugaron
mundial es un escenario único la jornada
de mañana la completa en ese duelo entre
uruguay y perú colombia contra bolivia
brasil contra chile y para el viernes
argentina contra venezuela